Trust among HISPs is another challenge.
Earlier we said that the HISP
established trust by
verifying that Doctors Johnson and
Jones are who they say they are and
that they are licensed physicians
in their practice state.
That's fairly easy to
do on a local basis.
Suppose, however,
that physicians in two states, or
even two regions of the country,
want to use direct.
They will almost certainly be
connected to different HISPs,
each of which established its own
policies for establishing trust.
Nationwide there could
be hundreds of HISPs.
Is each of them going to
have to investigate and
contract with all the others to make
sure they can trust each other?
That gets unwieldy fast, as shown here.
Direct Trust was established
to provide a solution
by establishing a trust community.
As the number of HISPs increases,
the number of trust
relationships needed doubles
as ten more HISPs are added?
Triples as 30 more HISPs are added?
Grows exponentially?
Depends on where the HISPs are located?